it might be the same thing it might be a
different thing but let me ask you a
ridiculously big philosophical uh
question about beauty
Dostoevsky said Beauty will save the
world in the idiot one of my favorite
books of his uh what is beauty to you
you've created through this intersection
of engineering and nature
you have created some incredibly
beautiful things what do you think is
beauty
that's a beautiful question
maybe it is connected to the love
question it is connected to the love
question of course everything is
connected to the love question okay
um
to me beauty is agency
to me something that has agency
it is beautiful there is this special
quote from Buckminster Fuller which I
cannot remember word for word fast I
remember the concept
which goes something like this
um when I work on a problem I never
think about beauty but when I'm done
solving the problem and I look at what
I've created and it's not beautiful I
know that I was wrong
okay yeah he's a kind of a an agency
that speaks to quote unquote the
objective function of the creation right
whether for Bucky it's useless or useful
so this idea of empowerment that you
talked about yes they connected to it
comes back to that yeah what's the
difference that you hinted at between it
empowerment and emergence is a emergence
completely lacks control
and empowerment is more
uh is more controlled
there's an agent making decisions is is
there an interesting distinction there
yes I think empowerment is a force with
Direction it has directionality to it
emergence
is I believe multi-directional again
that depends on the application
emergence is perhaps
in terms of sort of a material
definition is the isotropic spirit when
um empowerment is at the end is a Tropic
and counterpart
um
I think
they overlap because I think that
empowerment is a way of
um
inspiring emergence I think emergence
does not happen without empowerment but
empowerment can happen without emergence
do you think of emergence as the loss of
control like when you're thinking about
these capsules and the things they
create is emergence of things that is uh
not a desirable
conclusion I love that question because
to some of us the loss of control is
control
in design we're used to like extreme
levels of control over form and the
shape of a thing and how it behaves and
how it functions
and that's something we've inherited
from the Industrial Revolution
but with nature there is this
um
there's this diversity that happens
without necessarily having a reward
function right this is good or bad
things just happen and some of them
happen to have wings and some of them
happen to have scales and
you know you end up with this incredible
potential
um for for diversity so I think the
future of of design is in that soft
control is in the ability to design
highly controlled systems that enable
um that enable the loss of control and
creativity is very much part of this
because
creativity is all about letting go
and beginning again and beginning again
beginning again
and when you cannot let go you cannot be
creative and you can't you you can't you
can't find novelty but I think that
letting go is a moment that enables
empowerment agency creativity emergence
and they're all connected they're sort
of associate themselves with definition
of Destiny or the inevitable
a good friend of mine shared with me
elegant definition of Faith which is the
ratio of of who you are and and who you
want to be
pretty sure of who you are who you want
to be exactly and that sort of ends up
defining you yeah and those tools I
think when when when when you let go you
sort of find you you give peace to your
will right to a sense of Will and and
and so I think that's very very
important
in design but also in life